yann amandiers fondateur de
l'association utopia 56 bon jour ils
m'ont dit merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france vous avez donc
reçu une lettre de la part de
l'association la communauté hériterait
de calais ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire davantage si le décès est la preuve
que de qu'il ya des violences policières
à akalé on a souvent recensée des
violences policières depuis 2015 qu'on
est sur le terrain on n'avait jamais ou
très peu lu de d'exhiber qui avait porté
plainte et c'est ce que nous disait le
préfet et les forces de l'ordre à chaque
fois où sont les plaintes là aujourd'hui
à des plaintes elles sont assez violente
et sa montre et ça met en lumière aussi
la réalité de ce qu'on dit est ce que
les associatifs dit depuis des années il
y à des violences policières et
aujourd'hui cette communauté se saisit
de ça pour expliquer la réalité de ce
qui se passe aussi sur le terrain à
calais et bien sûr c'est pas toutes les
forces de l'ordre c'est la compagnie
numéro 8 qui a été cité et qui a
vraiment faire un sale travail à calais
quoi donc vous dénoncer des violences
régulières et non un acte isolé fait
bien fait c'est ce qu'on essaye de
démontrer depuis des années maintenant
c'est sûr que les exilés ont beaucoup de
mal à porter plainte mais des violences
policières
on en a on en a référencé des dites des
centaines de puits 2015 avec souvent pas
de plainte derrière donc ce qui n'a pas
emmené loin
aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose qui est
sur la table on a saisi le défenseur des
droits on s est dit saisi l'igpn s'est
exilé justement de l'igpn et du
défenseur des droits jacques toubon
l'igpn on l'a déjà saisi plusieurs fois
on n'a jamais eu vraiment de résultats
probants tout simplement parce qu'on
n'avait pas forcément justement ces
preuves de ces populations qui porte
plainte
aujourd'hui elle porte plainte
aujourd'hui disent aussi la réalité de
ce qu'est la vie pour ces populations et
est ce qui se passe à calais c'est à
dire harcèlement quotidien des forces de
l'ordre des démantèlements incroyable
tous les jours et de la violence qui
s'installe
au milieu de ce qu vide dans lesquels
dans ce moment dans lequel on devrait
tous essayé de faire quelque chose j'ai
envie de dire qu'à calais les choses
continuent comme avant
voire pire parce que ces populations
n'ont même pas eu le droit d'avoir un
confinement dans les règles de l'art
justement vous venez de parler du comice
vous venez d'évoquer le mot confinement
à quelle est la situation sur place
concernant cette crise sanitaire va vous
voyez les images de grande synthe des
images de calais depuis le 5 mars les
associatifs ont saisi la préfecture pour
demander des mises à l'abri organisé et
de saisir des hôtels je crois que même
monsieur xavier bertrand président de
région a demandé à ce qu'on saisisse des
internats qu'on mette ces populations à
l'abri depuis s'est passé quelque chose
sur les 1000 personnes entre les 1000 et
1200 personnes à calais 300 personnes
ont été mises à l'abri à grande synthe
opération d'envergure ce matin
arrestations des bénévoles d'utopia 56
qui sont au moment où je vous parle en
garde à vue tout simplement parce qu'on
était là pour documenter ou si ce qui se
passe sur le terrain et et c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe à calais
c'est c'est du non sens c'est beaucoup
de communication de la part d'un
gouvernement qui fait croire qu'il fait
les choses dans une communication et
derrière en fait la réalité est toujours
aussi toujours les mêmes avec encore
plus de violence comme en cette période
de confinement votre association utopia
56 s annoncent la rupture de ses
échanges avec à la sous préfecture de
calais ce que les relations sont arrivés
à un point de non retour
est ce que vous pensez à pouvoir renouer
le dialogue dans les semaines à venir
c'est pas possible de dialoguer ça fait
trois ans qu'on est autour d'une table
avec le préfet de calais aussi le préfet
de grande synthe à une certaine époque
en clair c'est pas de la communication
c'est tout simplement des préfets qui
nous nous invite à des tables de
négociations dans lesquelles rien ne se
négocie à part éventuellement une
communication de la préfecture qui dit
regardez je parle avec les associatifs
tout ça d une mascarade au vu des amants
de plus de 25 amant de référence et à
calais plus l'arrestation de nos
bénévoles la semaine dernière on a
décidé de dire au préfet que c'était
tout simplement plus supportable d'être
dans une mascarade de négociations donc
on a dit qu'on sortait de ces
discussions et on demandait simplement à
ce que soient respectés les droits des
droits de l'homme à calais les droits
fondamentaux de ces populations et je
vous invite
n'importe qui allait voir les conditions
d'hygiène dans lesquelles vivent les
migrants de grande synthe et de calais
aujourd'hui et vous allez bien vous
rendre compte que le confinement
n'existe pas que les mesures mises en
place par l'état ne fonctionne pas ou
très peu c'est de la com
et justement en parler de la crise
sanitaire à calais est-ce que vous avez
des chiffres concernant les cas de
contamination coronavirus des décès liés
aux copies de 19 à calais alors on n'a
pas forcément et c'est très compliqué
parce que il n'y a pas de tests il n'y a
pas de dépistage donc ce que je sais
c'est que il ya des acteurs comme
médecins du monde la croix rouge et la
protection civile qui oriente des
personnes vers des centres ceux qui ont
éventuellement des symptômes
je crois qu'il ya eu 2 kw à référencer à
calais la réalité je pense qu'elle est
tout autre mais dans le cadre on n'a pas
de dépistage est de retour sur les
personnes qu'on oriente je peux pas vous
donner de chiffres réels
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que c'est
quand même alarmant danse dans le cadre
de cette crise de ne pas pouvoir
imaginer mais mettre rapidement 2000
personnes à l'abri dans des hôtels de la
région dans des ya deux ans il faut en
fait ce n'est la volonté politique qui
n'est pas là merci il ya demandé d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes le fondateur de l'association
utopia 56